Americans pause today to remember and
celebrate the life of Dr Martin Luther
King Jr many participated in a Day of
Service this year marked 60 years since
the March on Washington and Dr King's
Speech demanding civil rights jobs and
freedom we will be remembering Dr King
throughout our newscast this afternoon
and evening earlier this morning the
annual Dr Martin Luther King Parade was
held in downtown Las Vegas Candace
Charles was there
well I've been an exciting a day here in
downtown Las Vegas as people come
together really from all over to enjoy
to honor and to celebrate the legacy of
Dr Martin Luther King Jr we've seen a
little bit of everyone from State
officials like Susie we've seen a couple
of dance teams as you can see we see one
right now coming on down and enjoying
we've seen of course some black
Engineers showing off some of their
robotics work uh Wendell P Williams who
founded Las Vegas is Martin Luther King
a day parade says that there were more
than 100 entries involved in the parade
there was definitely a little bit of
something for everyone we spoke to a
couple of people out here who said they
were just happy to see the community
come together in such a beautiful and
wonderful way one of the things that
honors Martin Luther King Jr's speech I
Have a Dream and of course we got to
speak with someone who was actually from
Morehouse Dr Martin Luther King Jr I'm a
mother says he went to school with two
of King's kids and really felt his
presence here today it's a very special
day it's a day of remembrance and
consideration for all of the sacrifices
that he made to build community we've
also heard from all over the world a lot
of people came out to enjoy and
celebrate again the wonderful Legacy
I've got their Martin Luther King and
Junior from downtown Las Vegas on Fourth
and gas where are their Doctor Martin
Luther King Jr parade started I'm
Candace Charles he's down